das universum hat zu uns gesprochen mit
diesen worten haben wissenschaftler die
entdeckung der gravitationswellen
kommentierte seine wissenschaftliche
sensation
sie kommt aus der entfernung von 13
milliarden jahren
professor harald lesch man muss sich
nach dieser entdeckung die ja großes
aufsehen hervorgerufen hat fragen müssen
wir jetzt alle unser leben ändern
nein ich glaube also bei veränderungen
von der größenordnung eines tausendstel
des durchmessers eines protons glaube
ich kann man sagen es nur großartige
wissenschaftliche entdeckung eine
großartige mesz leistung auch von der
präzision er wirklich einmalig aber die
relevanz für unsere unmittelbare
alltägliche tätigkeit unser handeln
sollen und wollen auf dem planeten wird
davon glaube ich nicht besonders
beeinflusst sein es gab eine schöne
karikatur im bonner general anzeiger da
sah man die die länder deutschland und
polen in so zu einem etwas titel den
zustand und die kanzlerin stand vor der
polnische ministerpräsident und sagte
ach unsere probleme der letzten monat
das war alles nur ein missverständnis
das haben die gravitationswellen
ausgelöst also das haben wir ganz sicher
nicht ausgelöst aber sie haben natürlich
in der wissenschaft insgesamt eine ganz
großen sturm der begeisterung aber warum
ist das eine so großartige entdeckung
wir wissen dass das mit der
relativitätstheorie von albert einstein
zusammenhängt und dass er das quasi
theoretisch schon einmal entwickelt
hatte das modell der gravitationswellen
er hat aber selber gesagt also die
chance dass wir das mal nachweisen
können sehe ich gar nicht warum ist das
jetzt eine sensation naja erstmal wir
haben 1915 ist die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie in die welt gekommen
ein schon hat sie veröffentlicht und wir
haben also praktisch jetzt wir sind
gerade kurz nach diesem 100 jahre
allgemeine relativitätstheorie daran
merkt man dass diese theorie offenbar
wenn sie jetzt in einigen ihrer
vorhersagen überprüft wird offenbar von
einer unglaublichen vorhersagekraft ist
aber was sagt diese theorie denn
eigentlich sie sagt nehmen wir mal an es
gebe eine 4 dimensionale raumzeit sei
nicht zunächst mal nur name und deren
form entscheidet darüber wie die licht
wege sind ist eine masse in dieser raum
zeit vorhanden
ist der licht weg rum ist keine masse
vorhanden bleibt der lichtweg gerade das
war die wesentliche vorhersage die auch
relativ schnell nach beginn der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie bereits
überprüft wurde dadurch wurde ein stein
ich zum popstar der physik und innerhalb
dieser theorie sind die wellen lösungen
praktisch eine ganz normale lösung also
wenn massen sich bewegen
in dieser raum zeit dann müsste diese
raumzeit auch in schwingungen versetzt
werden können und im grunde also wenn
man erst mal rein mathematisch das so
anschaut müssen uns ja klar das muss so
sein aber es scheint ja ebenso schwierig
zu sein wir haben alle vielleicht oder
viele die sich damit beschäftigen haben
so im kopf es gibt ein gummituch und in
den gummituch liegt eine kugel dann hat
man das da hat man den eindruck von
gummi und gummis ja sehr elastisch die
raumzeit ist 10 kva trillionen mal
härter und rigider als gummi also so
einfach kann man die nicht in wallung
bringen und das was da jetzt entdeckt
worden es ist natürlich von besonderer
exotik nämlich die verschmelzung von
zwei schwarzen löchern und ein schwarzes
loch ist ja schon der rand der
erkennbaren wirklichkeit da hat sich
masse unter ihrem eigenen gewicht so
verdichtet und kompakt ifi ziert das
kein licht mehr rauskommen und davon
auch noch zwei in einem
doppelsternsystem die sich umkreisen
also praktisch zwei geschlossene blasen
die sich dann zu einer blase vereinigen
und dann kann man ja aus dem signal das
wurde wunderschön gezeigt aus dem signal
der gravitationswellen kann man genau
sagen wie schwer diese schwarzen löcher
waren das eine hatte 9 20 mal so viel
masse wie die sonne das andere 36 wird
man denken momentan 29 36 es gibt doch
29 und 30 69 59 und 69 65 müssten 565
sonnenmassen schwarzes loch rauskommen
nein es kommt nur 162 sonnenmassen
schwer es war
wir haben sind die anderen drei die sind
in form von gravitationswellen
abgestrahlt das heißt also masse ist in
energie verwandelt worden und das auf
eine entfernung von 13 milliarden
lichtjahren und das auch noch bei längen
unterschieden von einem tausendstel
protonen durchmesser also genauer und
schöner faszinierender kann physik
eigentlich nicht sein aber es ist eine
katastrophe
oft zu dieser katastrophe kommen wir
noch aber jetzt brummt mir schon der
kopf weil roter zahlen und vor lauter
dimension die ja in der astrophysik sehr
typisch sind nämlich zeit und raum
dimension die man sich einfach
mensch nicht vorstellen kann fragt man
sich natürlich trotzdem diese
gravitationswellen die entdeckung warum
ist das jetzt ein so großer ein schnell
wir haben ja in der astronomie haben wir
verschiedene fenster das eine fenster
ist das fenster der elektromagnetischen
strahlung dafür haben wir menschen sogar
öffnungen wir können das sichtbare licht
der sterne sehen wir haben
radioteleskope damit beobachte mit den
radio bereiche unser auto
elektromagnetische strahlung ist uns
allen bekannte gibt es weitere fenster
der teilchenphysik das nämlich auch
teilchen von den fernen objekten zu uns
kommen die sogenannte kosmische
strahlung zum beispiel auch von der
sonne
ja und dann gibt es jetzt eben seit
neuestem das fenster der
gravitationswellen nämlich dann wenn
massen sich um massen herum bewegen dann
hat man einen neuen informationskanal
und zwar von vorgängen die sich
elektromagnetisch möglicherweise als
kamera blitz darstellen könnten wenn
also zwei schwarze löcher miteinander
verschmelzen könnte ein solcher gamma
ray burst entstehen das kennt man schon
aber das was man wirklich natürlich
wissen will ist ob unsere physik an
ihren grundfesten
so richtig ist wie wir glauben dass sie
es ist aber wenn man diese drei zugänge
hat
wir hatten zwei und jetzt haben wir eine
neue dazu genommen ist das etwas was
zusammen passt oder heißt dass die
widersprechen sich im zweifel auch so
ist es genauso also bei den schwarzen
löchern wie gesagt da ist man ja schon
am rand der erkennbar in wirklichkeit
ein anderer rand der erkennbaren
wirklichkeit der mit gravitationswellen
astronomie vielleicht mal untersucht
werden kann wenn wenn es immer bessere
und bessere und empfindliche detektoren
sind
das sind die gravitationswellen vom
anfang des universums also was ist denn
da passiert da müssen wir unglaubliche
massenbewegungen gewesen sein also muss
die raumzeit auch entsprechend durch
geschwungen haben und das müsste man
überall am himmel sehen so die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung in mikrowellen
beziehungsweise radiobereich sieht so
müsste man einen hintergrund am himmel
sehen an gravitation zu wählen und das
würde ja bereits mal annonciert im märz
2014 hat eine amerikanische gruppe in
einer großen pressekonferenz analysiert
sie hätten die gravitationswellen des
anfangs entdeckt stellte sich aber dann
raus das war ein messfehler und diese
gruppe jetzt hier live
die beiden lager
station die haben wir sogar den
zeitunterschied dass eine anlage ist in
washington die anderes in lousiana und
mit einem mit 7 millisekunden
zeitunterschied sind da die
gravitationswellen sie mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen da drüber
gelaufen also das ist natürlich ein
knaller und das signal was man da sieht
oder oder den vorgang den man da
beobachtet hat das ist ein textbuch also
ein lehrbuch vorgang bitte berechne wie
ist die gravitationswellen abstrahlung
von zwei massen die sich einen
bestimmten abstand voneinander mit einer
bestimmten frequenz umeinander bewegen
ich will jetzt nicht sagen das ist ein
übungsplatz ist aber das kann man also
mit die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
gehört hat dann kann man so was
ausrechnen
aber trotzdem bleibt doch die frage sie
sind ja ganz begeistert von diesem
experiment von dem ausgang ja alle
wissenschaftler die er stammt
beschäftigt haben sind enthusiastisch
sagen da haben wir eine neue dimension
aufgestoßen trotzdem komme ich zur frage
des anfangs zurück was nützt uns das
denn jetzt
in der tat sehen wir hier natürlich an
der grenze an der grenze angekommen wir
sind bei schwarzen löchern angekommen
das heißt die materie gibt keine
elektromagnetische strahlung ab wie der
innen drin
wir sind bei der lichtgeschwindigkeit
angekommen wir sind also praktisch in
der ebene der begrenzten oder der
grenzen der erkennbaren physik sind wir
bei mit diesen theorien angekommen und
deswegen ist diese entdeckung von den
gravitationswellen bzw
dieser erste direkte nachweis der
indirekte nachweis ist ja schon vor viel
viel früher passiert 73 74 schon als man
neutronensterne bei ihrer gegenseitigen
beeinflussung durch gravitationswellen
beobachten konnte es wurde anfang der
90er jahre auch mit dem nobelpreis
belohnt
diese entdeckung oder diese unglaublich
präzise bestätigung der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie ist eigentlich ein
katastrophaler triumph denn es bedeutet
dass die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
offenbar unglaublich richtig ist sie
stammt aber aus einer zeit lange vor der
quantenmechanik und die quantenmechanik
beschreibt aber die struktur der materie
also genau die form von physik die wir
brauchen um zum beispiel digitale
elektronik also computer
kommunikationstechnologie ict überhaupt
herzustellen alle alle unsere
manipulations fähigkeit des zwanzigsten
jahrhundert mit materie umzugehen
basiert auf der quantenmechanik jetzt
haben wir aber mit der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie eine theorie die dem
wirklich völlig gegenübersteht und das
sind zwei theorien die nicht zueinander
passen wenn aber beide richtig sind das
ist etwas das haben wir noch nicht
gehabt wir haben ja den drang in den
empirischen wissenschaften so was wie
eine vereinheitlichung zu schaffen und
dass diese und dass diese theorie so
verdammt gut bestätigt wird ist ein ganz
schlimmes zeichen für alle diejenigen
die auf der suche nach so großen
vereinheitlichten theorien sind um dann
am ende zu sagen wie das ganze die ganze
welt entstanden
das ist aber eben genau die frage es ist
eigentlich kein schritt der sozusagen
ein bisschen in richtung weltformel
hingegen sollte eigentlich das gegenteil
das wäre eigentlich die wissenschaft
jetzt frustrierend festzustellen so
einfach ist das nicht wir hören nicht
einfach linear nach vorne gehen und
irgendwann werden wir an einem punkt
sein wo wir alles verstanden da haben
sie völlig recht zu die theorie
entwicklung ist das eine große
herausforderung die wir in der
astronomie halt immer wieder haben mit
dunkler energie dunkle materie jetzt mit
dem gravitationswellen das alles deutet
ja auf eine form von physik hin die aber
immer nur am rande der erkennbar an
wirklichkeit ist ich hab' muss ganz
ehrlich gestehen
als ich nach dem ersten nach dem ersten
enthusiasmus über die gravitationswellen
direktion habe ich gedacht das rokoko
physik eigentlich haben wir genau wie
sich eben gesagt habe wir haben
eigentlich relativ geringen
erkenntnisgewinn weil das wussten wir
schon das ist die bestätigung des
bereits bekannten das ist rock also wir
müssen eine unglaubliche mesz leistung
vollbringen das muss man sich wirklich
in allen einzelheiten dann mal auch mal
anschauen kann ich nur alle ermuntern
dazu sich anzuschauen was es eigentlich
bedeutet mit solchen vier kilometer
langen laserstrahlen solche differenz
versuche zu machen und das so genau zu
messen
pac man muss sich überlegen tausendste
protonenradius im proton ist schon irre
klein wenn also ein atom so groß wie
fußballstadion ist ein proton so groß
wie ein reiskorn im mittelpunkt des
anstoß kreises und da sind 99 prozent
der gesamten masse drin und davon ein
tausendstel himmel normal doch was ist
denn das für eine physik die da gemacht
wird und ich bin ganz sicher an dem tag
es gab keine gravitationswellen
skeptiker und daran musste ich denken
denn das ist die wissenschaft die physik
ist die wissenschaftlich auch zum
klimawandel dazu gehört oder zur
energiewende
das heißt überall da wo wir so nette
geschichten vom rande des universums
erfahren schwarze löcher die
verschmelzen unter urknall und am besten
noch dazu da sind die leute total
begeistert wenn man ihnen aber dann mit
den gleichen methoden mit denen wir
schwarze löcher untersuchen oder
gravitationswellen wenn wir mit den
gleichen methoden hervorbringen wir
haben so viel treibhausgase wir haben
ein problem mit dem klima wie gehabt
werden mit dem fossilen brennstoffe
nicht so weitermachen können usw
dann heißt es nun in dem moment mal so
das kann ja wohl nicht sein
wissenschaft hat ja auch immer etwas
sehr faszinierendes vor allen dingen
wenn sie so faszinierend ist dass man
nicht versteht was tatsächlich passiert
wir sind an einem modell des schwarzen
lochs oder das ist etwas was die
menschen fasziniert wenige begreifen was
da eigentlich passiert vielleicht muss
der wissenschaftler wie sie auch sagen
wir werden es auch nie begreifen oder
zumindest im augenblick können was nicht
was ist denn ein schwarzes loch ein
schwarzes loch ist mathematisch einfach
eine lösung der einsteinschen feld
gleichungen nämlich als einstand seiner
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
aufgeschrieben hatte geht es am
gravitation was ist gravitation da kam
eben auf den gedanken dass die
anwesenheit von masse die geometrie
verändert und das sieht man hier in
diesem modell der wunderbar wir haben in
der mitte offenbar ein objekt drin und
die so kugel die da um dieses objekt
herum sich bewegt die reagiert darauf
dass der raum nicht flach ist sondern
dass er in der nähe dieser mulde
gekrümmt ist
das heißt die bewegungen von etwas in
der nähe dieses schweren objektes die
werden eben auch immer gekrümmt sein zb
kann man sich vorstellen sind die
planeten um die sonne herum und wenn das
aber ein schwarzes loch ist dann hat man
es mit einer sehr kompakten masse zu tun
man kann praktisch ausrechnen
ab welcher menge von materie in einem
bestimmten volumen wird ein objekt so
kompakt dass noch nicht einmal mehr
licht entweichen kann und das nennt man
dann schwarzes loch und hier zum
beispiel diese kugel wird hier nicht
mehr rauskommen
festgemauert ist es nicht in der erden
sondern das wird der reinfall wird
irgendwann tatsächlich im schwarzen loch
wenn es denn ein schwarzes loch
darstellen soll hier dieses dieses
sogenannte potenzial dieses schwerer
fällt wird in dem schwarzen loch
verschwinden
wenn wir wenn wir jetzt im zusammenhang
mit den gravitationswellen begriffen
haben oder versuchen zu begreifen dass
da zwei schwarze löcher waren die 13
milliarden lichtjahre zurück liegen
deren schwingungen wir quasi jetzt
offenbar haben messen können was ist das
findet dimension was ist denn da
passiert was ist das schon knall gewesen
es war so erstmal also erst mal dass
zwei ganz normale sterne das werden also
das heißt ganz normales bank große
sterne die in einem doppelsternsystem
und sich ineinander umkreist haben und
irgendwann war in den sternen die fusion
von atomkernen zu ende das ist ja dass
deshalb funktioniert jan stern weil bei
der physik kernfusion wird energie
freigesetzt diese energie drängt nach
außen und die eigene schwerkraft hält
den stern zusammen
es ist aber irgendwann bei der
kernfusion ist es zu ende kennt man ja
vom periodensystem der elemente also bei
eisen 6 eisen ist zunächst einmal die
energie freisetzung zu ende dann wird
dann kollabiert der stern unter seinem
eigenen gewicht und dann entscheidet
seine masse darüber ob in seinem innern
ein schwarzes loch entsteht oder nicht
nur sehr schwere sterne werden am ende
ihres lebens als schwarze löcher übrig
bleiben haben wir also zwei schwere
sternen doppelsternsystem dann bleiben
zwei schwarze löcher übrig und das was
man da beobachtet hat ist eigentlich gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich nämlich zwei
sternleichen die einander umkreisen
so wie eben diese kugel dar ein
gekauftes so sind diese beiden schwarzen
löcher praktisch geschlossenen raum zeit
blasen
dies sind sich immer näher gekommen weil
sich aneinander gerieben haben und die
reibung führt dazu dass die die
rotationsenergie dimitri energie weniger
wird und irgendwann verschmelzen zwei
seifenblasen zu einer also ich schon die
stimme wird schon tiefer weil die masse
wird größer und bei dieser verschmelzung
werden drei sonnenmassen bei dem actemra
gemessen hat wird die entwirrt die masse
von drei sonnen in energie verwandelt
nämlich in die energie die diese
schwarzen löcher gebraucht haben um
miteinander zu verschmelzen und damit
die raumzeit in bewegung zu setzen wir
alle können letztendlich diese dimension
dessen was sie gerade beschrieben haben
eigentlich nur verstehen wenn wir das in
st
von zeitraster hineinsetzen da sind wir
ganz ganz kleine teilchen weil unser
zeitraster ist so 80 lebensjahre wenn
wir von diesen milliarden lichtjahren
hören dann kommt doch eine zeit
dimension hinzu die wir nicht mehr
begreifen können
das ist zwar schön für sie da können sie
nullen dran waren und das sind riesen
gleichungen aber letztendlich ist das
eine dimension die eigentlich für uns
noch irgendeine art von interesse hat
außer dass es fasziniert das ist eine
ganz schwierig zu beantwortende frage
weil die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
als die theorie von den großen massen
von den hohen geschwindigkeiten und der
theorie des kosmos als ganzen auf der
einen seite aber auch die
quantenmechanik also die
elementarteilchenphysik als die theorie
vom allerkleinsten diese beiden theorien
die das sind ja theorien in welten von
der bar jeder anschauen sind wir haben
keine form mehr wo man sagen kann auch
klar das kann ich mir vorstellen sondern
wir merken eben bei beiden theorien dass
wir eine sprache benutzen müssen die
eine hohe kompression fähigkeit für
informationen besitzt die allerdings uns
im grunde genommen als mensch nichts
mehr sagt nämlich mathematik wir haben
sie mit mathematischen strukturen zu tun
und diese mathematischen strukturen
haben folgerungen in der wirklichkeit
das heißt wir können uns auf einmal
können wir uns zu geistigen höhen
schwingen die anderen lebewesen völlig
verstellt sind also man könnte es mit
kopernikus sagen der mensch ist kein
tier denn wenn er ein tier wäre würde er
sich nur auf seine sinne verlassen und
den sinnen gemäss dreht sich alles um
uns aber kopernikus war eine der ersten
sachen denkt doch mal es gibt höhere
prinzipien dann lernen wir mehr die
struktur der wirklichkeit als nur von
unseren sinnen und das ist natürlich
hier bei der relativitätstheorie und
auch bei den gravitationswellen genauso
wir sehen hier einfach den triumph
dieser empirischen methode immer im buch
der natur nach den gesetzen zu suchen
die man quantifizieren kann
ob das die wichtigen gesetze sind das
ist damit noch nicht gesagt aber sind
die einzigen die sich sozusagen
unabhängig von den kulturellen
traditionen von ideologien von
hoffnungen träumen oder visionen
zwischen den subjekten so kommunizieren
lassen dass die was von einander
verstehen also 1&1 es überall auf der
welt 2 ganz egal ob man ein
kommunistisch oder imperial
oder ob man atheist oder was auch immer
die mathematik ist davon völlig
unabhängig das heißt sie ist so objektiv
wie es nur irgendwie möglich ist den
rückschluss bedeutet das natürlich noch
lange nicht das alles und ob das die
welt nur aus den dingen besteht die
messbar sind
dann kommen natürlich in den weiten
bereich der menschlichen zwecke ziele
und so weiter wieder rein und darüber
sagt einem natürlich so etwas wie eine
allgemeine relativitätstheorie gar nicht
ist sie gehört zu den ich würde mal
sagen inventur theorien sie sagt einfach
was der fall ist
und das heißt noch nicht dass wir die
naturgesetze die wir bis jetzt
identifiziert haben dass das wir schon
alle kennen aber das ist das minimal
aber wenn wenn die frage des großen
goethe was die welt im innersten
zusammenhält
letztendlich von der wissenschaft trotz
dieser enormen präzision
trotz dieser unglaublichen erkenntnisse
die sie liefert letztendlich eine
mathematische gleichung ist was habe ich
denn davon
es ist das eine böse frage an den
wissenden leid ich würde ich würde mit
goethe antworten es ist ein teil des
teils der anfangs alles war denn das was
wir eben damit mit empirischer
wissenschaftler erforschen ist der teil
der welt der empirisch zugängliches wir
wissen als menschen sehr wohl dass es
teile der welt gibt die zwar von uns
selbst erfahren werden können nämlich
unsere selbsterfahrung wir sind aber die
nicht gemessen werden können man kann
unsere mentalen zustände messen
aber was es bedeutet nicht groß zu sein
weiß nur michael kohtz sonst niemand
denn ihre zeitliche dimension
ihre erfahrung ihre lebenserfahrung ist
nicht nachweisbar nur sie haben das
heißt es gibt erfahrungen die man nicht
messen kann aber es gibt eben auch viele
phänomene die man sehr genau messen kann
und da sind wir inzwischen einer
präzision angekommen die ja nur noch als
unmenschlich zu bezeichnen ist die ja
auch nur noch mit anlagen überhaupt
bewerkstelligt werden kann
für die man selber bereits wieder
computer braucht die computer überprüfen
also die genauigkeit die wir hier haben
von 10 hoch minus 21 oder sowas
das ist ja völlig ab aber aberwitzig
professor lässt das ist faszinierend das
ist großartig das ist
mathematik hoch wie auch wie immer die
frage ist nur was haben wir davon wir
wollen mal schauen ob wir zum beispiel
durch den blick ins all ein bisschen
noch über uns mehr erfahren können und
ob es überhaupt sinn macht ins all zu
starten wie das ja immer wieder gemacht
wird mit raketen
sprechen wir mal über raumfahrt und
möglicherweise auch die weiterführung
der bemannten raumfahrt
wenn wir über raumfahrt sprechen
sprechen wir von einem phänomen was in
den 60er jahren die menschen fasziniert
hat es recht bei der landung auf dem
mond was inzwischen als völlig normal
angesehen wird nicht nur weil ganz viele
satelliten telekommunikationen
geheimdienste und so weiter um die erde
kreisen
auch eine us es also eine raumstation
die um die erde kreist wird gar nicht
mehr wahrgenommen
das spannende ist irgendwie so ein
bisschen raus jetzt gibt es eine mission
exomars die wird versuchen weil
nachzuweisen ob es leben auf dem mars
gegeben hat in welcher form auch immer
macht das sinn das überhaupt zu erörtern
zu erforschen der aufwand ist ganz groß
und wir haben genug probleme auf der
eigenen ehre dass letzteres sicher
richtig warm genug probleme auf der auf
der erde
aber manchmal das haben wir die
astronauten schon gesagt die entweder
die erde umkreist haben oder sogar vor
allen dingen die die zum mond geflogen
sind
manchmal muss man sich von zuhause
entfernen um zu wissen in was für einem
paradies man lebt und wie wertvoll das
ist was man gerade verlassen hat das
wäre bei der mission zum mars sicherlich
nicht so einfach weil der flug zum mars
dauert mindestens sechs monate und
irgendwann verliert man diese
wunderschöne blaue perle im hintergrund
und vor allem der rote planet wird
einfach nicht größer aber ich glaube als
internationales als internationales
großes projekt wäre es ganz wichtig sich
mal wieder etwas vorzunehmen was auch
öffentlichkeit fasziniert öffentlichkeit
ganz allgemein wird wenn etwas sich
immer wieder wiederholt also quasi
automatisch ist dann verliert die
öffentlichkeit an interesse es muss
sowas her wie ein klares ziel und wenn
das ziel erreicht es muss das nächste
ziel formuliert werden und muss auch
erreichbar sein
aber wenn dinge sich praktisch wirklich
so roboterhaft
automatisieren und die faszination der
der iss ist ja immer wieder da wenn
jemand neues kombi zum beispiel
alexander gerst gemacht hat dann gibt es
ein kontakt dafür aber man muss
natürlich schon sagen die öffentlichkeit
insgesamt ist nicht so wahnsinnig scharf
darauf wie das noch den 60er jahren war
wobei alle mitgefiebert haben werden die
denn auch den mond erreichen oder bei
apollo 13 ganz besonders kommen unsere
jungs auch wieder zurückverwandelt diese
drei amerikaner waren drei von uns und
da hat hat china genauso mitgefiebert
wie argentinien oder der vatikan also es
war ein globales phänomen und das
projekt macht insofern natürlich sinn
ein roboter da hinzuschicken aber
irgendwann werden auch persönliche macht
es denn überhaupt sinn dass astronauten
so etwas machen
vor zehn jahren war thomas reiter auf
der iss ein halbes jahr dort oben
gewesen er hat von dem blauen planeten
geschwärmt er hat uns alle am gewissen
gepackt und werde sagt überlegt mal was
ihr dafür ein paradies habt ja den
begriff gerade auch benutzt und passt
auf dass das nicht schiefgeht alexander
gerst hat das auch getan er seinen
besuch auf der als es trotzdem hat das
nicht wirklich zu einer wiedererweckung
der verantwortung der planeten gegenüber
mehr
im gegenteil wir haben so das gefühl wir
sind in einer isolation der krisen um
uns herum was sollen wir damit der
weltraumfahrt wie gesagt das ist was die
unmittelbare erdbeobachtung betrifft
gibt es ja inzwischen so viele
verschiedene informationskanäle dass die
iss und die astronauten dann immer nur
der sogenannte menschliche faktor sind
das sind welche von uns wenn sie dann
wieder nach hause kommen können sie uns
was darüber erzählen und wie ich vorhin
schon mal sagte was natürlich nicht
erlebbar ist für uns ist die innere
dimension der erfahrung der diese
menschen gemacht haben das wird für
immer in denen drin bleiben sie können
darüber reden so viel sie wollen
letztlich ist es eine erfahrung die nur
von von denjenigen gemacht werden kann
die da draußen ist wenn es um die
nächsten planeten geht also namentlich
um den mars geht das ist natürlich eine
alte frage gibt es noch leben im
sonnensystem oder hat es nur auf unserem
planeten geklappt wäre wichtig zu wissen
ob der mars dass so ein habitat gewesen
also ein bewohnbarer planeten aber es
gibt noch eine ganz andere geschichte an
die meiner ansicht nach viel zu selten
gedacht
liebermann der weltraumfahrt geht das
ist die gefahr durch asteroiden
einschläge wir brauchen eine task force
in der lage wäre innerhalb von wenigen
jahrzehnten darauf zu reagieren wenn
astronomen herausfinden es gibt einen
ein schläger von der kilometer größe
oder noch größer und der wird uns in
absehbarer zeit auch den nächsten 20 30
am besten 100 oder 120 jahren treffen
dann müssen wir in der lage sein einen
solchen ein schläger so aus seiner bahn
abzulenken dass er die erde nicht trifft
das ist ein vorgang der nicht zu
automatisieren ist sondern das wird eine
ganz einzigartige aufgabe werden wo
meiner ansicht nach originalität
fantasie und wirklich auch querdenker
vor ort sein müssen um vielleicht
probleme zu lösen von denen wir hier auf
der erde
wenn wir da nur ein roboter hinschicken
würden noch gar nicht mal wissen dass es
diese probleme überhaupt gibt wir haben
jetzt gesehen
rosetta mission haben den filiale da
stellen wir uns für winzigen moment vor
es wäre jemand da gewesen an dort der
diese kleine sonde dann auf diesen
kometen gelingt hätte die wäre genau
auszug ganz sanft weich auf dem kometen
gelandet weil die person wäre vor ort
gewesen wir waren jetzt licht minuten
davon entfernt wir hätten gar nicht
reagieren können
das ganze automatisierten mondlandung
wäre auch schief gegangen wenn kein
mensch dazu ist es nun aber nie hatten
mobil am sekunden hat das ding mit der
hand gelenkt und solche situationen
tauchen immer wieder auf und gerade bei
so einer bedrohlichen beim chronischen
szenario ich will jetzt hier niemand
dazu aufrufen sein lebensversicherung zu
kündigen aber es ist ja nicht die frage
ob ein asteroid auf die erde einstieg
sondern nur wann
irgendwann werden solche brocken ihr
einschlagen und ein warnsystem haben wir
schon werden schon gute beobachtung
systeme für viele viele dieser körper
die im erdnahen raum im relativ
moderaten abständen die erdbahn kreuzen
aber wir müssten viel mehr dafür tun und
wir müssen dann natürlich bei
gefahrenmeldungen auch in der lage sein
entsprechend zu reagieren und deswegen
würde ich sagen wir machen immer noch
viel zu wenig bewandert weltraumfahrt
denn sowohl die iss als diese langzeit
erfahrung wie reagieren menschen auf
schwerelosigkeit wenn sie lange im all
sind was für experimente kann man da
machen wie bekommt man überhaupt klar
das ist sowohl für den flug zum mars
wichtig als eben auch wenn wir mal über
eine ganz lange dimension nach
dass die menschheit sich vor einer
solchen kosmischen gefahr retten können
sollte aber gehen wir noch einen kleinen
schritt zurück und sagen das kann ja
irgendwann mal sein
das könnte sehr viel schneller sein dass
diese erde so wie wir mit dem umgehen
wahrscheinlich unbewohnbar
da gibt es schon die ersten die sagen
alles kein problem wir gucken im
weltraum befinden irgendetwas dann
siedeln wir uns um
abgesehen von der ideologischen
komponente dabei ist das ein
realistisches szenario also wir sind
hier unter uns
das ist völliger schwachsinn einfach nur
schwachsinn
man kann weder den mars zu einer neuen
erde machen der maas hat nur zehn
prozent erdmasse das heißt das sind
inkontinente planet der kann nix halten
sagen gemeinden 25 jahre hin genau als
der mars kann nichts halten die venus
ist zu heiß planeten um andere sterne
herum sind lichtjahre von uns entfernt
ein lichtjahr ist eine riesengroße
strecke mit der technologie die wir
heute haben würden wir bis zum nächsten
stern 75.000 jahre brauchen
also ich würde mal sagen zunächst einmal
sollten wir zusehen dass wir unseren
eigenen planeten so schätzen und so
vorsichtig behandeln wie wir nur können
und dann können wir vielleicht
irgendwann mal darüber nachdenken in
ganz ferner zukunft ein generationen
raumschiff loszuschicken das wird sich
dann vielleicht irgendeinen planeten
suchen aber wir haben die verantwortung
für unser jetzt und für unsere
unmittelbare zukunft und da wird uns das
universum nicht helfen werden wir
menschen haben wenn sie das generationen
raumschiff erwähnen nicht die bereit
sind dies zu tun nämlich sich von der
erde zu lösen und irgendwohin zu
schweben wo auch immer ohne dass sie die
sicherheit haben können oder sogar
sicher sein können dass sie nicht mehr
auf die erde zurückkommen können es gibt
ja erste die bereit wären einen solchen
werten menschen so etwas aushalten
können ins all in das schwarze zu
fliegen ohne jemals wieder zurückkehren
zu können also wenn sie es nicht
aushalten wenn die ganze mission
scheitern
kann sich vielleicht ein bisschen damit
trösten dass man anfang des 19
jahrhunderts auch nicht gedacht hat dass
man mit 30 oder 40 stundenkilometer mit
einem zug sich bewegen kann da dachten
alle
man wird zerquetscht werden wir rasen
heute im flugzeug mit 900 kilometer in
der stunde um den planeten herum also
was lebewesen alles aushalten
das ist wirklich dann eine sache der
empirie das muss erforscht werden
deswegen betreiben wir ja momentan auch
eben mit raumstation raumfahrt aber auf
die ganz lange sicht müssen wir
technologie entwickeln dafür
und wenn wir technologie vertrauen dann
halten wir das ja auch aus wir haben
wenn wir uns heute in unsere automobile
setzen da machen wir uns keine gedanken
mehr darüber welche komplexe technologie
davon da drin ist und ich glaube auch
für eine raumfahrer eine zivilisation
würde in ferner zukunft irgendwann
raumfahrt einfach sowas sein wie es
heute für uns die busfahrt ist muss man
sich natürlich darüber klar sein es
werden ressourcen gebraucht diese
ressourcen wären dann ressourcen von
planetare dimension eine raum fahren der
zivilisation wie sie zb in science
fiction filmen oft dargestellt wird
die verbrauch die ressourcen von ganzen
sonnensystemen
da ist es also nicht mehr damit getan
einen eigenen planeten so zu auszuräumen
sondern muss man asteroiden ausräumen da
muss man andere planeten ausräumen man
kann ja mal so die für spaß sich die
frage stellen so was wie dieser todes
planet bei star wars wie viele metalle
müsste man denn da zusammenkratzen um so
ein ding überhaupt hinzukriegen
geschweige davon dass man das auch
konstruieren kann
das ist alles ferne science fiction da
bleiben wir lieber momentan vielleicht
er bei seiner vorstellung mit dem
marciano diesen film wo man klar gemacht
wird aha wir könnten ja irgendwann mal
zum mars fliegen
und wer weiß was man auf dem mars alles
findet aber möglicherweise werden wir
nur feststellen dass wir auf einem sehr
staubigen planeten gelandet sind und
dass der schönste platz im ganzen
universum
der planet ist den wir erden entsprachen
sie schauen als astrophysiker begeistert
in den weltraum wenn sie die möglichkeit
hätten eine solche exkursion in den
weltraum zu unternehmen ohne
zurückzukehren
sicher sein zu können dass sie wieder
auf die heimat auf den heimatplaneten
zurückkommen aber unglaubliche
erkenntnisse übermitteln könnten würden
sie das machen
lessing hat mal auf so eine frage
geantwortet wenn mir gott anbieten wird
die ganze wahrheit oder immer nur die
neugier auf die wahrheit dann würde er
sich immer für die neugier entscheiden
weil die ganze wahrheit ist nur für
einen gott
ich würde lieber weiter fröhlich und
neugierig sein und auf meinem planeten
bleiben
das universum ist sehr faszinierend aber
es ist mir zu groß
es ist mir zu lehr- und wichtige
menschen in meinem leben wären nicht in
meiner nähe und das ist es nicht wert
professor harald lesch das genick